uh talk about uh you've been on some  wild tours man obviously I remember when  you first kind of had like your big tour  where you were headlining  um what is the craziest like backstage  experience at a little pump show that  you remember happening  hmm  experience  I'll tell you what I remember once I was  overseas  what city was I in I told everybody I'm  gonna throw my ass in the lake it was in  um  you were in Germany throwing yourself in  a lake yeah there was a lake next to the  festival right I told everybody [ __ ]  this [ __ ] everybody coming here with me  won't took all my [ __ ] off had all my  fans literally jump jump it was like  literally like 3 000 people they all  just follow me to the lake was it cold  cold as [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I regret it I  was like oh my god get me out this [ __ ]  right away right away what did I do yeah  but  this show is so insane and another one  was um I'll say wireless Festival in the  UK UK it's insane fire insane yeah